[Music]
the liberal aim to try and Achieve Civic
peace is a good aim I would challenge
you particularly given the last few
weekends we've seen since October the
7th to say that we have Civic peace but
my my response to that from within the
liberal tend is to say that liberalism
needs to be muscular so what we then
have to say is the healthy form of
conservatism the healthy form of
liberalism we Face a common enemy
sometimes in order to preserve and
conserve change is necessary and that's
the big challenge that conservatism
faces just as the liberal faces the
challenge when do you stop liberating
and start becoming a
conservative hello everybody and welcome
to the first what will be many debates
here on trigonometry I'll be hosting
some Francis will be hosting others I
cannot tell you how delighted I am to be
joined by two of our favorite ever
guests on the show Dr James o and
Professor Steven Hicks welcome both
thanks we're going to have a debate
about conservatism versus liberalism uh
you've both written a couple of pieces
for my substack and there'll be more
coming um I want Stephen you you you had
to go second in the written debate so
I'll go to you first um one of the I
thought more persuasive criticism of
liberalism and we heard it a lot of it
at ARK where we all were a few days ago
uh was that limits are liberating and
the pursuit of unending freedom is
actually destructive to society what do
you say to those people well uh I think
gift is start with a moral conception of
what Society is uh uh we start with
individuals who are both the agents uh
individuals have agency you don't see
them as pawns pushed around by forces
beyond their control so there is a
conception of human nature at work and
that's a that's a philosophical starting
point not only of Agents but of moral
worth that whatever we're doing in
society that we're forming various kinds
of social institutions businesses
religion families governments and so
forth it is with respect to the value of
the individuals involved so we come
together to do business as individuals
we form families it's two individuals
who come together uh making a voluntary
choice and they then bring into the
world another individual right that
needs to develop his capacities for
agency and and moral self-
responsibility so it's not that uh uh
freedom and individualism is corrosive
of the social it's rather that the
social exists to preserve the
individuals and enable individuals
better uh uh by you division of labor
being coordinated achieve the values of
the individuals when those social
institutions are no longer serving that
function they should properly be
dissolved and this is and new ones
created and this is partly why we're
going to have an evolving and in some
case revolving Society
so it is making clear what your ultimate
moral standard is some social
institutions should be dissolved uh uh
but that requires uh uh that you've made
clear what your moral standard is and
you should have no problem with some
social institutions going by the by uh
and you should be actively preserving
other social institutions because
they've proved their worth at uh uh
protecting the rights and values of the
individuals involved but I what people
mean is when we look at the real world
out there right now is the dissolution
of certain institutions uh has led to
increasing atomization of people people
feeling disconnected from each other
from society um and that's why I think a
lot of people are now starting to talk
about um I would say it's not Freedom
that is causing people the atomism right
that people are worrying about so very
have to get to say what do we mean by an
atomized individual or an isolated
individual or an individual who has come
to be in an adversarial relationship to
what we think of as a healthy social
institution and I think when you drill
down and start looking at cases it's not
going to be too much Freedom that's the
problem what is the problem well it
depends on when you drill down which
kind of atomism you are worried about so
if you uh uh uh wanted to say for
example you have uh individuals on
social media who are feeling
isolated uh from the world and it's a
teenage who are considering suicide now
you might then say well we shouldn't
have given these powerful liberating
devices to them in the first place
because they don't know how to do it but
I think uh uh what's actually happening
in that particular subcase is you've got
young people who are trying to develop a
self and they are going into in most
cases what are Echo Chambers uh and then
instead of developing a self what they
are doing is just echoing and reflecting
what's going on there and you have a
certain amount of mob action with
respect to those individuals the mob
action is not anything that is
respectful of the individual so you have
uh a a social environment right which is
not conducive to healthy development of
individuals uh inste you've got a kind
of I would say Collective mob psychology
that's destructive that's going on there
so you do end up with isolated
individuals but it's not too much
Freedom it's mob
psychology very interesting and James I
want to put some of the Steven's
critiques of conservatism to you in the
second but uh did you pick up anything
there you wanted to come back on yeah
thanks well and thanks for putting this
together it's a great honor to be part
of the first trigonometry debate and
it's been great to exchange views um in
writing with with Stephen thanks for uh
thanks for orchestrating it Vick
canstein says at one point that a
picture held us captive and I think a
picture holds the liberal mind captive I
think it's a myth it's a very attractive
myth but it's a false myth and you might
call that myth something like like a
kind of secular creationism the secular
creationist believes that freedom and
equality kind of pop into being from
nothing round about
1776 Sunday afternoon in April about tea
time I think this is false I do not
think that the natural resting state of
human beings is to be free to exist
without any unchosen obligations to be
simply primarily an individual and to
take it as self-evident that every
individual has an equal moral worth that
there is some readily available moral
standard that all individuals left at
their own devices will exercising their
rationality discern track and live out I
think there's a reason that liberalism
emerges in the 18th century it's not
because it starts ex nio from nothing
but because it is the fruit of a long
centuries an accumulated wisdom and
tradition beginning with the helenic
tradition fusing with the hebraic
tradition and resulting in the end yes
through fits and stance as we it's a
it's an it's an process of evolution
there's some Revolution too and when
there is Revolution that's when things
get ugly um so there a big difference
between I think the American Revolution
and the French Revolution so that just
to sort of you know set the scene for my
um for sort of my position I don't think
it's true that we are born into the
world as individuals freely just
deciding what obligations to undertake
we're literally born attached to a cord
to our mom that that's how that I think
is is the is the more plausible account
of how we start as human beings
Aristotle makes this point in the
opening of the politics we are before we
are creatures of the poce before we are
Political Animals politicon Z on we are
paired animals that is to say we pair
ourselves male and female we then
naturally express ourselves through new
human beings new life that itself is an
unstable setup we need to form ourselves
in into a village Villages are
vulnerable as we learned kibutz is are
vulnerable we need to expand and we need
to form together and now for total the
best unit for a moral Community a stable
social moral order was the poce that may
vary from era to era maybe the city
state it may be a nation state it may be
a relatively stable
Empire so that I think is a is a much
more um empirically aligned and accurate
account of what it is to be human now of
course of course it's not to say that
freedom doesn't matter and it's not to
say that we don't freely take on
obligations further down the line we
choose our spouses we may not choose our
parents or our siblings uh we may not
easily choose our nation uh you've
chosen Britain um but not everyone and
most people rest with the with with with
the the moral community in which they
find themselves we might say well we
freely enter into uh a marriage now
historically that's been seen as a CO a
covenant a lifelong promise liberalism
changes that turns it into a contract
why it has to be a contract James just
explain the difference for people what
is the difference between a covenant and
contract there's a lot of literature on
this but let's say roughly that a
covenant is a unilateral promise and
commitment that is not that that expects
reciprocity but doesn't require it a
contract is um and it's a and it's has
some sort of public um public features
it's something that you make before
others that is known about is publicly
known it's not a kind of private
arrangement I think that's an important
element too
it's not a contract the contract is the
sort of dominant metaphor for the whole
for the liberal Universe social contract
could be a vertical contract with the
state as as Hobs stresses in Leviathan
or I think more plausibly it's a loan
contract with that we you know we enter
into so the language of consent
individual rights I'm free to enter the
contract and I'm free to breach it if I
do breach it then there are certain
maybe obligations I might have to comp
um make up for and so on and so forth
now again I think that um abstracts and
uh sort of legalizes and removes uh
human Arrangements away from our Natural
State very quickly just the final point
this question of moral worth that the
that the sort of the liberal uh mind
assumes that moral worth and objective
moral standards are not only available
but universally available the liberal
project is a universal project
conservative projects tend not to be
though I'll when we come to talk about
conser I'll say a little bit more about
that CU I think there's some criticism
that's can to be made to the
conservative position on that front so
the liberal Paradigm is a universal
Universal universalizing Paradigm that
is to say human rights is universally
applicable that is the sort of standard
Yar stick that's the standard Manifesto
for Liberal morality And yet when we are
when we press the liberal on what what
what is this moral standard and we and
the liberal says well we all agree on
this we all have to agree on this you
realize that it's impossible without
surrendering freedom of thought without
surrendering the freedom to choose RI
what will always be rival and
conflicting concepts of conceptions of
the good John rolls the by far and way
the most influential liberal political
liberal of the last 50 years devises
this thought experiment Liberals are
always devising thought experiments
because precisely because they want to
abstract away from particular contingent
concrete circumstances to imagine this
kind of universal Timeless Utopia that's
applicable to all times and to all
places and in this thought experiment he
says well in order to pull this off in
order to imagine a maximally just
Society we have to bracket quote our
comprehensive metaphysical commitments
now what lies within that
phrase everything not just the god stuff
what it what we are as human beings
conceptions of human nature what makes
us free what our worth consists in these
are inevitably contentious moral
contentious philosophy iCal questions
that are not never going to command
Universal agreement the only reason
there's an illusion of agreement that
emerges at the 18th century is precisely
because there's been a settled
intellectual social and cultural pattern
from Plato and Aristotle all the way
through late Antiquity the high Middle
Ages and emerging into fruition yes with
big political breaks like the
Reformation in the 16th century and the
French Revolution in the 18th century
but those are kind of optical illusions
those revolutions lead us to believe
especially the way history is taught in
the textbooks you've got the
enlightenment well what comes before the
enlightenment Darkness what comes before
Renaissance death and so there's this
sort of as I said there's a kind of myth
there's a mythology to liberalism that
thinks that it all starts with a break
and it I say it's not it's the fruits of
the very order that conservatives seek
to preserve thank I I want to come back
to conservatism a second but still the
flurry of punches there so come back on
this well particularly the the idea that
liberalism uh is interfering in things
like marriage and and changing the way
that we do things so beautifully said
but three huge right topics right uh put
out there and I'm going to take just the
first one well yes I start to it yeah
that's right okay so let's take this
first one about the the liberal Mythos
right uh that somehow in the
enlightenment there's this radical break
with the past and suddenly liberalism
we're all free autonomous self right
that is a a conservative myth about
liberalism there are no liberals now
John rolls is a disaster we'll come back
to him in a moment he's your guy he is
not he is the opposite of my
guy this that's the third topic that you
that you are putting out there every
single uh important liberal in the
tradition right liberalism does have its
tradition will say look by the time we
get to the enlightenment you are exactly
right uh the you know the founding
fathers of the United States are saying
no we have to go back to Greece we have
to go back to Rome there are certain
long political Traditions at the same
time they are very well aware if we are
interested in religious freedom for
example the First Amendment uh we're in
Britain but I'm going to use the this
American example in the in the Bill of
Rights in the First Amendment the very
first thing is freedom of religion and
it's very clear that this comes out of
already two centuries of battles over
Rel religious freedom religious
toleration and so forth uh the more
broad ranging intellectual freedoms in
The Sciences for example it's already
two to three centuries of debates over
whether we should be intellectually free
in The Sciences or not to extend to
Artistic Freedom are we going to censor
the theaters or are we going to allow uh
literary people to do whatever already
going back to the Renaissance we have
now more than two centuries we have
three to four centuries of debates and
hard-fought battles so what we have then
is a multi-front battle with respect to
the Arts with respect to the Sciences
with respect to religion with respect to
all of the Civil freedoms and so yes
absolutely the enlightenment is a
Capstone and there's a kind of aha
moment that many intellectuals are
reaching in the 1700s after we fought
all of these particular battles now we
are in a position to generalize and say
it's not just artistic Freedom or
religious freedom or scientific Freedom
or freedom to go into whatever kind of
business you want yes we are going to
generalize to these Universal principles
so the myth is and this is often a
conservative reading that somehow uh
we're springing denovo into existence I
don't think that's a proper reading of
liberal the Liberals are proud of their
history now to turn the tables a little
bit if we then say the Liberals want to
say in the social order uh there are
going to be lots of values that are are
contested on and there's going to be a
great deal of uh of evolution that goes
on where the Liberals are insisting that
Liberty comes first is in one area and
one area only that is in the political
area when we are talking about families
when we are talking about other
institutions people might have different
orders of uh what their values are and
we might have contending values in those
social but when we are talking about
politics specifically when we are
talking about government we have to be
very very clear because government is a
in every single Society a an instrument
of compulsion it makes its rules all
other social institutions of course have
rules but those are rules that are
flexible OB you can opt in and out of
business opt in and out of a church uh
uh uh opt in and out of playing this or
that sport so they all have their rules
but those are particular rules for those
institutions and people voluntarily sign
on to them when we're talking about
governments we are talking about a
different kind of animal right and it's
an 800 lb gorilla animal that says our
rules are going to apply to everybody in
the society and our rules if you break
one of these rules the police are going
to come to you we will put you in jail
if we find that you are wrong and we
have these rules with respect to foreign
people protecting our people you come
here we will use our military so when we
are talking about um uh uh the moral
order right uh uh the Liberals are
insistent the purpose of government all
of the universal rules and the
willingness to use Force against any
anybody it has to be only with reference
to the protection of individual
liberties that's where the insistence
comes in that's where the uh the uh the
enforcement comes in now now against
that what I read from Professor or and
other conservatives now conservatism of
course is a big tent so I'm going to try
to tailor it as much as possible to
yours as to say well we can't do that
because we have to have a prior kind of
order right within which individuals
come into existence and that order has
hierarchy archical elements uh uh and it
has traditions and so we have order
tradition hierarchy and those are going
to be values that Trump Liberty in many
cases including in political cases and
that's where the liberal gets worried
right because then we want to say well
there are good orders and there are bad
orders there are good hierarchies and
there are bad hierarchies how are we
going to sort those out you do need a
principle before you a moral principle
to sort out all of those values you
can't just start with all of those and
if we then go back to the history and
this is why I think the the myth the
conservative myth about the liberal
history is important we say in you know
over the course of the centuries when
all of these hot hardfought battles are
being won they are being won by the
Liberals they are not being won by the
conservatives in every single generation
we go to the late 1400s and we say we
need you know this is a generation of
Michelangelo Leonardo a little earlier
and so on the artists are saying we need
artistic freedom and it is precisely
conservatives right of that era that are
saying no order and tradition that is
stifling the liberal developments there
in the next century when we're talking
about religious freedom it's uh it's uh
the Liberals of that generation saying
no individuals need to take charge of
their own conscience get the state out
of it uh and so forth and it is
precisely the people of order tradition
and hierarchy who are stifling that
development of individual liberty in the
case of science when the scientists like
Galileo are saying you know stop
torturing scientists start using
intimidation uh we need to be
freethinking and and and liberal in this
intellectual zone is precisely the
conservatives of that era saying no
order and tradition and hierarchy and so
forth so what I think the right way to
read this history is that what has
happened is that Liberals are in all of
these areas the ones who are fighting
the batt battle making the progress It's
the conservatives who are reactionary in
varying degrees some of them are just
saying no and using Force compulsion to
stop the advance of those ones but then
the more reasonable conservatives
typically once the battle has been won
by the Liberals they accommodate and
they say okay now we will fold this into
the tradition uh but it is now a uh a
liberal conservatism right where the
Liberals one that did the work the
conservatives accommodate that after and
then uh you get to what I think of as
more reasonable conservatives in the
later modern world J yes of course I'm
conscious that we're we're sort of we're
firing a lot of rounds at each other we
should really take them one by one but
that's just the first issue put on the
table let me just let's try and I'll try
and impose we only have like an hour and
a half total so if maybe we'll maybe
you'll let us do a sequel but so let me
just let me take respond to to to your
responses so is the first question of
the the narrating of the history and and
and the conservative myth that
liberalism pops into being out of
nothing the kind of the secular
creationism line that I started off with
there's also this question about
government and the state that it's only
in the political Arena that the
liberalism values freedom and then
questions about artistic freedom and
science let's just let's just go with
those four there I know there are lots
of other points that you um that that
you made that I'm sorry if I don't
address them look the historic the sort
of periodization question that it is The
Enlightenment I you know that is how
it's tall that I think you know I'm I'm
I think there's a lot to your reading or
your renarration but I think it is a
renarration I think it is a sort of
heter heterodox take I wish there were
more liberals who were running this I
think it I think when conservatives say
that there is this
Enlightenment moment uh that is talked
about that's the metaphor that's used
that we talk about the Dark Ages the
Middle Ages why are the Middle Ages
between what between the high noon of
classical Antiquity and The Rebirth of
uh humanism leading to Enlightenment I
just think that is the way things are
told just look at the labels they don't
they don't lie I mean I don't I think
they do lie I think and I'm glad that
you agree with me that they lie but that
I think is the standard School
University textbook story and I don't
think it's I think it is a myth but I
don't think it's a myth that
conservatives think that it's a myth if
you what I mean we can keep talking
about that and but I think it takes us
on to a point that is will be helpful
for our discussion which is that we
we're probably the way that this is set
up we're probably being a little bit too
binary uh we've been Constantine you
know be very upset with this this is we
we got to seek to be a little bit
non-binary the there's a sort of
pendulum swing so the idea is that you
know the liberal is doesn't care at all
about the sort of order that might
constrain us and and provide the
enabling conditions of freedom for
virtue as opposed to Raw anarchic
freedom and
conversely the conservative can can
ignore the fact that freedom actually
has been you know part of our history as
a as in western civilization way way way
back to democratic Athens paresi I think
of the importance of freedom of speech
within the Athenian assembly or isonomia
I think equality before the law these
are clearly liberal ideas I completely
accept that what I say is that there's a
kind of crystallization of of kind of
constellated themes around Freedom the
two engine rooms of liberalism from the
early modern period onward freedom and
equality that's the French Revolution
that's the American Revolution that's
what gets in in in the late 18th century
okay so that that's the first point this
second point about how liberalism is
only worried about freedom in the
political
space now I think if that's
true it actually confirms my worries
that the liberal has this another myth
that there is a kind of secular neutral
Public Square in which we're all free
because we've bracketed any contentious
commitments that might lead to to more
nasty religious wars or Civil Wars or
whatever that might be now I think
that's that's true that it's and it's
and it's praiseworthy the liberal aim to
try and Achieve Civic peace is a good
aim we all want Civic peace I deny if we
look around the cities of the West right
now if we look at the fruits of the
liberal project as it as they currently
exist I would challenge you particularly
given the last few weekends we've seen
since October the 7th to say that we
have Civic peace James I know you have
so much more to say but I feel like on
that particular issue that is a very
good one to hone in on do you mind if we
do let's do yeah Focus what do you say
to that because I think a lot of people
will feel like you know the Paradox of
Tolerance the fact that we uh have
allowed people uh into this country who
don't share our values because we are so
welcoming and tolerant and liberal has
created a society where because of the
freedom we provide to people it is the
the most tolerant people who are now in
the Public Square shouting things what
what say you to that well I think then
we need to bring in a at least one more
player under the social and intellectual
scene aside from liberalism and
conservatism and that third or fourth
player is going to be the problem case
so we're talking about a hopefully
sophisticated version of liberalism a
sophisticated version of conservatism
but there are lots of
unsophisticated philosophies ideologies
and worldview out there how conservatism
will handle them how liberalism will
handle them that of course is a is a big
project uh but I think it would be
faulty to say that somehow conservatism
is responsible for that uh uh and I'm
not going to make that argument uh but I
think it also doesn't work the other way
that to say that liberal going to make
that right no no no but I right I
understand so uh right there is then
another uh and there is of course a
grain of truth to this that you know
liberalism again is a big tent just like
there's you know very hidebound versions
of conservativism and then there are
more flexible evolving versions of
conservatism as well there are versions
of liberalism that start to sound very
Namby pambi uh and these are going to be
the more free floating rationalistic
versions of liberalism that you are
worried about and I also worry about and
uh you know they are so concerned with
saying we need to respect other people's
freedoms that I can never uh even
criticize other people and so from that
intellectual context then you're going
to get into a paradox of Tolerance but
my my response to that from within the
liberal tent is to say that liberalism
needs to be muscular if I can use that
metaphor once you have said individuals
matter individuals have rights and we do
have to come back to this universalism
versus particulars the localism issue
for sure uh um uh and that even if you
want to elevate that and to say we are
certain about that and that these rights
are absolute then you Empower government
to protect those rights then that
government needs to be muscular in the
protection of those rights so just as we
say for example uh you know there you
know any sort of murdering is wrong it
violates the right to life kidnapping
and enslaving are wrong uh uh theft is
wrong so life liberty and property the
government should be EMP powered to
whatever degree necessary to uh use
Force effectively in the service of
those three rights so the the point of
the so-called parabox of Tolerance is to
say pretty much anything that is
voluntary and peaceful is going to be
tolerated and so it is going to be a
largely contentious messy society and
there's going to be a lot of value
conflicts and so on and we're going to
try to resolve those as much as we
possibly can through voluntary
mechanisms but when we are clearly
dealing with someone who is not
interested in doing that they are
inserting Force into the equation then
the police come down hard on those
what's happening and that is not so
that's the second part of it why is that
not happening and it's not because
liberalism is not saying we should no we
shouldn't protect uh people's Liberty
rights or we should allow assassination
and killing and kidnapping and so forth
it's the third contenders who are both
anti- liberal in their core in their
origin and they're significantly now
part of the society and you we have let
a lot of them in and uh significant
number of the more intellectually
sophisticated have captured certain
institutions so what we then have to say
is the healthy form of conservatism the
healthy form of liberalism we Face a
common enemy which is the illiberal
versions of various other let me you're
most welcome to let me just get into a
slight ly more nuanced Edge case because
let's say that the you are for muscular
liberalism and you will crack down on
anybody who commits acts of violence I
think that's a minimum standard for a
healthy Society absolutely what about
the fact that for example we all have
freedom of speech in the liberal
conception and yet I don't think the
conservative would support and I not
necessarily being conservative would
support the idea that someone should be
able to walk into the Public Square and
publicly chant gas the Jews for example
as people did in Australia or shout
pramas slogans but the liberal
conception taken to its logical
conclusion is well they're not hurting
anybody physically yeah they have
freedom of speech why should they not be
allowed to do that well my first answer
would be what should sound like a good
conservative answer which is to say on
all of these edge cases right we have
now many centuries of common law
discussions about precisely those and in
the did nor American tradition right we
have a shorter right tradition of
exactly those sorts of things and so to
get as nuan as possible then you have to
go into all of those common law cases
and say what has Law worked out when
they are attending to all of the
variables there so no and then I would
say uh who is responsible for that
public space and if it's a public space
then the way we have worked things out
right now is the government is
responsible for it and they are
responsible for the administration of
that public space including if it's like
a hides Corner kind of place uh in a
place where at a minimum still people's
lives Liberty and property is going to
be respected any speech that goes in the
direction of incitement right and where
the line is drawn between uh speech that
should be tolerated and when it becomes
incitement that has to be very nuanced
but once that line is crossed then I
would say yeah muscular liberalism you
shut that speaker down all right all
right well I can see a rare so just just
a few things to say I mean this this
idea that conservatism and liberalism
have have got uh these sort of mutant
siblings and that that we could we all
we're both in a position where we need
to deal with the problem that that this
third Challenger presents us with I I I
think that the the what we're seeing the
chaos The Tyranny the atomization to go
back to your early Point constant and we
can talk about this later I think the an
the atomization and the Tyranny are
structurally complicit features of
liberalism and I'll explain why later on
if we if we've got a moment but um the
if you start with the a view of human
nature of human beings as basically free
rational autonomous self- legislating
agents who freely enter into obligations
and ties you just do think of human
beings as basically fungible it's hard
to think of therefore it's it's
impossible to come up with a moral
objection to large numbers of people
coming into your country entering your
moral community on no not on terms that
you set for them Beyond barely minimal
ones of you know don't celebrate Terror
and don't kill people right there's no
there's no sort of there's no sort of
ethic there there's nothing within that
those abstract Universal liberal
principles that's actually going to
command the concrete loyalties of flesh
and blood human beings what commands the
Loyalty of flesh and blood human beings
is family neighborhood uh Corporation
religious communities G builds maybe
secular communities and I think Nations
I mean I think nation states are the is
the outermost limit of those concentric
circles of political affections and
loyalties Beyond which they become
abstract nobody nobody's going to sort
of get up and nobody's going to die for
the European Union no nobody's going to
get up and and put their hands on their
hearts and sing Oh to Joy with when the
EU flag I mean maybe some will in
Brussels but you know it's not so and is
lon so so so the conservative par is to
say look we are what we are it would be
wonderful maybe if we were these perfect
liberal rational uh autonomous uh beings
but that's just not what we are and one
of I mean if you look for example at the
doctrine of multiculturalism that is a
paradigm liberal Doctrine what it says
is we are not going to make any demands
on you even when you enter into our
moral Community as to how you understand
uh the the fundament fundamental moral
questions we're going to say we're not
one culture we're many cultures so we
can have as many silos as we want and
because of the sort of doctrinaire a
priori commitment to the idea that it
doesn't matter because whoever's in the
silos they're all liberal rational self-
legislating selves who will left to
their own devices uh just see that um uh
equality goodness and the United Nations
Declaration of Human Rights is the only
moral code worth living by and uh more
primary superseding political loyalties
to one's orang country uh will just
magically fall away as you pass through
the passport gates at he thr there just
a sort of magic wand and you just you
know forget all of those loyalties
forget all those concrete attachments to
Kin and to family to ethnicity to tribe
to religion to origin country and we
just become a British Citizen and I just
think that's that's another myth I think
it's plainly false and I think it's why
what we're seeing on the streets of our
liberal Western C Capital Cities all
over at the moment is a fruit of
liberalism and it those fruits th those
effects those consequences would not
have Arisen on a truly cons in in a
truly conservative poity that is to say
a PO that says this is not just any
random collection of of of of individual
agents these are a people they are they
are French they are from papun guini
they are from Australia they've got this
story and not any other this is these
are the people we we've over the years
as you say the common law that is
something this is the moral code that
has slowly evolved and over the long
history of of our people that is the
settled wisdom of our people the
Paradigm for liberals is not the common
law it's rights-based regimes it's
rights documents it's the Declaration of
Rights it's the European human it's
European Court of Human Rights it's the
very conventions and documents that is
making that is paralyzing today's
conservative government in the UK from
deporting these people who are
celebrating the terrorist attacks on
October the 7th uh Stephen uh come back
quickly because we've spent uh almost
all the entire time interrogating the
liberal position want to come to
interrogate you in the conserv position
but come back on this so very good then
I think we're in if we take that line uh
and say there is this myth of the free
rational autonomous atomized individual
and we want to put the blame on
liberalism for where we are then I think
the argument is there going to be
liberalism has not been tough enough on
people who are not going to adopt that
position and now then you add to that an
understanding of human nature what
commands our loyalties and so forth that
you think uh Li liberalism uh is not in
keeping with and so it's just it's going
to be a failed project we don't dive of
documents well sometimes we do but then
the to go to the other side of what I
think would be a false dichotomy here
then would be to say what conservatism
then is to say is we start in a
particular context and we are bound to a
particular religion a particular family
a particular language and a whole bunch
of particular things and if you then
that's not just a metaph for if we are
bound and constituted and our identities
and our value structure comes to be
formed in that particular context then
you are uh uh going to be very close to
a kind of relativism because then you're
going to point out that obviously people
are born into all sorts of different
local contexts all over the world and
they're going to be very different in
various ways and If you deny the
capacity of us as rational people to
abstract from from those differences to
see a common Humanity excuse me a common
Humanity then you're going to say all we
have is contentious groups but from this
conservative position you're going to
see no way out of it because what really
binds us what commands us and notice how
strong that language is is these
particular tribal loyalties and if you
are then worried about the people who
are doing terrible things out on the
streets of London and various other
places it's precisely those people those
are the people the conservatives are
describing and valorizing because those
people are tribalists who were born into
a certain tradition a certain language a
certain family structure and they are
bound and commanded by it the conserva
arum presumably would be we don't let
people from a different conservative
culture us that's right so then you want
to balkanize the world into the
different tribes baniz your own Society
okay quite well okay so but notice what
I said though that I think is a false
alternative okay so somehow what we need
to do with the healthy conservative and
the healthy liberalism is to say we are
not culture-bound relativists and all
the best that we can do is relativize
versus we are some sort of free floating
individual right rational agents and
just anything goes right that's the
false alternative we need to get past to
get to the next stage of the discussion
and how do we but I I I I'm very keen to
to understand but I don't yet Stephen
right so this is I think where the
epistemological issues come in is it
possible for individuals to uh whatever
their particular circumstances they are
born into to rise above the say I was
born into this religion but I'm not
bound to this religion I am going to
think it through as an adult do some
comparative religions and as a rational
individual with good education and free
exploration I can make my own decision I
was born into this family but I don't
just uncritically accept this family cuz
some families are dysfunctional some
families are functional and I am going
to learn the lessons of my family
structure and I'm probably going to do
better in the next time so we have the
cognitive power to rise above our
circumstan no denying that Noy the
conserv let me come back to this yeah
well constant you you you take there's a
lot of directions we could go I'm just
wary that I I don't want it to be all
one way CU can I just say I think this
pivots very neatly to a criticism of
conservatism that I think is very
powerful if not the most powerful this
is the relative charge so maybe we can
maybe this is a good point to which we
can sort of turn to to to to to
criticize my my position um it but just
just as as we're going at the relativism
can problem I think is baked in even
more so I don't think it is baked into
conservatism and I'll explain why but I
think it is structurally baked into
liberalism remember liberalism is the
view that we are free to choose our
conceptions of the good we are free when
nobody's going to tell us what our
metaphysical conception of human nature
is and that just is going to lead to
conflict we're going to just have rival
conceptions of the good that's why the
adjective plural is often attached to
Liberal plural democracies the liberal
in attaching the word plural basically
concedes that the Canan project the
Canan idea that left to our own devices
we're all going to come up with a
singular conception of what a
flourishing society looks like was never
going to work at all so liberal plural
societies how do we then cope with that
well what happens is we have plural
conceptions of the good how do we police
and navigate and manage and integrate
these how do we hold a Multicultural
Society together stepen you're
absolutely right you need an 800 pound
gorilla the conservative says you don't
need the gorilla or at least you can
keep the gorilla in the cage and you
know bring him out only in exceptional
circumstances if you have a moral
community that has a clear self-
understanding of it itself it has a
clear a pride in itself a pride that it
can confer as it welcomes new guests to
join its moral community on the terms
that it sets for themselves both with
the gifts that it offers but also the
duties that it expects and because this
this is us this is this is distinctive
this is the kind of community we are so
I think you know the relativism problem
does emerge naturally from the liberal
tradition but let's turn to conservatism
because I think there you you're
absolutely right Stephen say this is
this is also this is not not a problem
that conservatism is free on free from
if we're all conserving our own
particular Traditions isn't that itself
a recipe of relativism I mean how are we
going to how are we going to cope with
that well my first response preliminary
response would be to say um so what it
better to be a bulcan ised world than a
bulcan ised society we can at least
navigate international relations not
easy there Wars but much better to have
uh divisions conducted along through
diplomacy and War Tri among nation
states than within a nation I get let
let me put a different criticism I the
most persuasive one that I thought you
put in the written part of this debate
which is that if conservatism is about
the preservation of order and
traditions without the universal vision
of what human beings are supposed to be
able to do and how they're supposed to
be able to live we would still have
slavery women would still be second
class citizens and so and so so forth
what say you to that good well I mean I
think it it's I mean notice what happens
when uh let's let's just take the
Abolitionist Movement uh in this country
this the first Abolitionist Movement
leads to the abolition slavery in 1807
and the slave trade in 1833 how does it
start it starts with a criticism that
comes from evangelicals Thomas Clarkson
St John's College Cambridge William
wildforce St John's College Cambridge
they start making theological arguments
about that say there is there can be no
debate there can be no rival conceptions
of the view that human beings are not
Canan selves but Divine beings made in
the image of God with an irreducible
dignity and preciousness and for that
reason this is Clarkson's it was an
undergraduate essay the essay on the
Commerce on on the Commerce of the human
species which became the manifesto for
the Abolitionist Movement I think
conservatism
preserves and inherits Traditions that
carry within it the seeds of its own
reform we see this with the Abolitionist
Movement we see it too with the logic of
extending the franchise to women who
which which tradition is the first to
lift up women I say it's Christianity
look at the way in which women feature
in the gospels now look I don't want to
get into a theological AR by the way
Christianity really conservative
religion I I don't know that's a whole a
whole other debate but let's simply say
that the the the Christendom and the
inherited moral traditions of
Christendom are what broadly speaking
conservatives in the west are are
seeking to preserve and I think what
what we're tiptoeing around here I don't
want to get down into the religion sort
of WR down a religion rabbit hole but I
do just want to say that this is my
deeper answer to your worries about
relativism there are many conservatives
who are secular uh I think that part of
what the conservative is preserving is
a set of transcendent metaphysical
commitments and
obligations and uh what that means is
that it's not just uh uh it's not just
relativism it's not just everything's up
for grabs there is a subtle way of
understanding what who what human beings
are it's not the conception of human
nature that emerges very rapidly in the
18th century who who are the big
thinkers of the French Revolution um dri
he writes L machine in the 1760s I think
that is say man is mechanism look at um
the DAR Darwin the sort of great
developments and reductive conceptions
of human nature in 19th century we're
basically just animals we're in you
we're out for ourselves and look at how
that gets Allied to Liberal doctrines of
capitalism in the in the 20th century so
I think we've got you've got a very
clear Transcendent sort of theological
undercurrent that I think the best
conservatism does it does in fact
preserve that's the that's why it's not
ultimately relativist there are timeless
Eternal Transcendent truths that yes
have particular expressions and that
will vary from time to place human
beings evolve over time human culture
evolves over time um but but there is a
kind of anchor if you like in a set of
uh a basic Traditions that are both
revealed and rational Stephen make some
of your arguments because I thought that
was one of the strongest among others no
I think James is absolutely right
ultimately we are going to have to get
back to metaphysics uh everything's done
metaphysics metaphysic and the
epistemological issues about abstraction
there are people watching this I want
them to stay watching simp we're not
going to do but I will make the history
point just to start with the the the
abolition of slavery you are exactly
right that by the time we get to the
1700s it's evangelicals who are uh front
and center and a significant uh member
but I think that's the wrong reading of
the abolition story and it's not going
to be something internal to
Christianity uh that is uh get the
credit for the Abolitionist Movement and
its successes and the point is going to
be that Christianity was the dominant
intellectual framework from
300s right and it had a monopoly
basically for 700 800 900 years not a
whisper against anything being wrong
with slavery or well I can give you
aerth Century the institution of slavery
the institution of the subordination of
women for well over a millennium when
you get to the 1700s and you have some
evangelicals and others this is already
three centuries after the Renaissance
the first people to start significantly
see saying there's something wrong with
slavery are in the 1500s and they are
Renaissance humanist educated
individuals who are starting to say
there is something wrong here with uh
with this as an institution and that
picks up in the 1600s as we go through
the religious battles uh over religious
toleration separation of CHA church and
state it what you find then is a new
form of Christianity and I would say
John locks is probably the best version
here where you have a combination right
early Enlightenment right uh uh uh
philosophy combined with uh trying to
make Christianity as reasonable as
possible with it certain understanding
of individuals Toleration freedom and so
forth once that is is put in place and
this is by the end of the 1600s then in
the 1700s you've got a whole bunch of
people who are now Renaissance humanist
types including you know Benjamin
Franklin and the Thomas Jeffersons and
so forth and a whole bunch of
evangelicals who are now coming out of
this new form of modernized Christianity
then and only then does slavery uh get
go on the defense of inoya and then the
same story would be told with respect to
women now that's just the first half of
the history story okay well look let's
we we can we can have a sort of History
War here and I just I just think that I
just think it's a mistaken way of
understanding the history uh the
evangelicals are not reading Lock's
reasonableness of Christianity they're
reading the New Testament and and but
they're reading it through a lock J
would it not be fair to say though that
the people who are most opposed to the
emancipation of women and the uh the
lifting of the enslavement of uh
Africans are also conservatives and
Christians I think it's I think it's an
the binary to the 18th century when the
word conservatism doesn't even emerge
people who believe in the preservation
of the existing so so yes you're you're
absolutely right the conservatives do
put a Primacy they think that the the
default presumption uh when faced with
any kind of radical change should
be uh stay with what you've got now if
you like that's the converse problem of
that the liberal has the liberal has
doesn't know when to stop liberating and
has to stop at some point before if it
does if the liberal doesn't stop
liberating you end up with a tyranny you
just have individual conceptions of the
good an atomized society that can only
be held together by a tyranny and and
that I think is where we're getting now
now but just just to say the
conservativism a conservative position
suffers from you know a similar a
similar kind of problem um you what you
what you've got in um in the well late
late 18th century is the emerg is the
idea that we've got a settled a sort of
subtle hierarchy we've got a hierarchy
that works hierarchies are functional
flat uh uh uh flat sort of societies
with no sort of distinctions of sort of
office and function are dysfunctional
societies and so and we recognize this
and I think conservatives have sometime
have often been guilty and no doubt they
were guilty in the 18th century of
conflating value and dignity with
function that is to say um that is to
say if you have high office somehow
you're invested with greater moral work
I think that does emerge in the 18th and
19th century but only because the
theological conceptions of of a full
blooded metaphysical human equality
before uh before God priest and paa
kneel together at the at the altar rail
that starts to dissipate and as that
starts to dissipate it becomes very
difficult for hierarchies to seem
morally okay it because there it just
seems it just seems random the only way
you can understand equality is really in
material terms the asate the allocation
of offices and also increasingly salary
salary and wealth but that is what human
weth consists in it's a kind of
secularizing and a materializing of of
of human worth so yes I mean the conserv
the cons conservatives have to
understand that sometimes in order to
preserve and conserve change is
necessary and that's the big challenge
that conservatism faces just as the
liberal faces the challenge when do you
start stop liberating and start becoming
a
conservative
anything you want to say on
that well again we have number of issues
here in part I think this comes down to
partly a temperamental issue right where
the conservatives is a little more
backwards looking not not any pejorative
sense we look backwards to look forwards
yeah what what what we have accomplished
and the the liberal is forward-looking
how can we how can we improve from
Ground Zero the conservative wants to
change slowly the liberal is more
willing to say we we got this great new
ideal and let's go for it uh and that in
part uh for the intellectuals I think
does turn on the epistemological issues
this is about knowledge when do we know
and the thing that I think most liberals
will find temperamentally objectionable
is this conservative resistance
to uh the idea that we can in fact
discover truths moral truths that are
universalizable and act on them quickly
now this is partly then an
epistemological confidence in the power
of the human mind and I think that one
requires another discussion of its own
so I would you know in history
philosophy terms my sense is you are
much more Burk conservative and I'm
going to be much more lock
liberal this where I think it becomes
morally important that if you are in
these
1800s and you find someone saying given
everything that we have discovered right
now are you not certain with moral
certainty that slavery is an Abomination
yeah it is
disgusting right and that we know this
that slaves are human beings with full
dignity capacity for
freedom and I am ready to generalize on
that uh and if if someone
temperamentally says well I'm not sure
yeah right uh you know my tradition blah
blah blah that that's going to be the
moral objection to conservatism that it
builds of course but it's going to build
into itself a resistance to something
that is and then to say well we should
change slowly say no this is wrong we
should change quickly on this and then
the same thing that say if there's any
sort of resistance once we recognize
that women are capable of
self-governance rationality running
their own lives free agency that well
you know our tradition we're not so sure
about the generalization all women are
you sure right and so forth no that is
right morally objectionable so I think
that it's going to be an epistemological
issue that is partly a temperamental
issue but it's going to come into a a
moral conflict about okay I think it's
very helpful actually Stephen to frame
it that way I think I think you're right
it's an epistemological question and I
think you're also right that it that it
bleeds very quickly into a moral
question and I and I think the
conservative comeback would be to say
yes we are indeed very nervous when a
set of traditions that been running for
centuries and R are being challenged and
completely subverted and started again
from we're starting again from Ground
Zero by a small gaggle of people who
just have uh read lots of books and
written lots of sort of uh Furious
tracks about how we we must change
everything right now yes there's a
nervousness there why because the
conservative puts uh uh takes very
seriously the idea that the tradition is
the Democracy of the Dead that there is
an accumulated wisdom in Tradition and
even if we don't fully understand that
is say even if we don't have
epistemological Clarity of why it is
that that fence is up in the field we
know that somebody at some point put it
up there we don't know if there's an
angry bull somewhere hiding behind a a
tree about to about to attack us but
we're not going to put it down that is
to say we're going to understand that
rationality is not always does not is
not always contained within a single
head or a single sort of little group of
heads that is to say rationality is a
point that haek makes even though he
doesn't say it he denies is a
conservative rationality is dispersed
it's dispersed in all sorts of ways it's
dispersed in the price mechanism it's
also dispersed in the common law as you
said earlier that is to say what is the
common law the common law represents a
tradition of epistemological humility
the rights-based documents declarations
day noo are represent the liberal
epistemology that is say we've got it
right we've got the universal
application we're going to write this
document and it's going to be applicable
from here on in at all times in all
places we might put in a few amendments
if you're lucky that the conservative
approach is it no these we must respect
the accumulated the the sedimentation of
moral wisdom over the past yes that's
going to mean we're going to have to
Creek and change as new technologies
emerge as new as new Wars and conflicts
emerge it's not it's not a recipe for
stasis and and paralysis but it's an
Adaptive method and it recognizes that
we're not just going we don't have some
sort of omniscient Clarity just because
happen to be the ones walking around
alive at the moment James and Stephen we
have a few minutes left and there's one
thing I want to bring up that you
mentioned there briefly that I think
actually has doesn't get talked about
enough because people who think for a
living like the two of you and just to a
lesser extent me we sometimes want to
believe that changes in society and
progress whatever we call that is
primarily driven by ideas and by culture
whereas I think it's fair to say to a
large extent it's driven by technology I
think that's such a great point if I
could just follow it then I just uh well
and you know our good friend Luis Perry
for example makes this point about the
sexual Revolution we can talk all we
want about the emancipation of women
because we're so Progressive but
actually it happens because we finally
have the technology for it to be
possible if I can just pick up on that
point and marry it to Louise's wonderful
work and and the work of of the other um
British feminists new reactionary
feminists you know if it it's true that
that the sort of liberal impulse has
been a recipe for moral progress I don't
want to deny that but there's a big
difference when when it comes to
thinking about what is it that what's
the sort of understanding of human
beings that's motivating that moral
progress Stephen and I differed on what
motivated the Abolitionist Movement I
say it was evangelicals what is what are
evangelicals they're the ones who go
back to they're always banging on about
the Bible they're not reading John lck
they're reading Paul and they're and
they're seeing that that that what what
unfolds there is the sort of the logic
of all human beings being equal in in in
the eyes of God
now that's different from the liberal
conception which sees human beings as
fungible that there's no ultimate
difference between human between men and
women that that we're just units and I
think that is why transgenderism emerges
that ideology for example emerges that
confusion between men and women emerges
within from naturally Downstream of the
liberal conception of human nature as a
kind of basically Blank Slate U empty
vessel so but back to your point um
Constantin you're right that what
catalyzes these changes is not just
ideas and and Stephen and I you know
we've been talking about ideas and the
history of ideas and so on it is true
that we academics often you know think
that idea put a lot more uh um attribute
a lot more to ideas as factors in of
historical change than we ought to
technology matters uh as Louise argues
the the pill in the 1960s has an a
massively transformative effect the
invention of the washing machine
as Mary hington points out has radical
trans Etc not just technology though law
uh many have argued uh Christ
Christopher cwell recent most and
Richard hania recently in in the origins
of wokeness the Civil Rights Act 1964
has an enormous change in how we
understand uh uh on the sort of the
moral Universe of society I'd say in the
UK context I would add human right the
equivalent would be the Human Rights Act
1998 and the equality act 2010 this has
become our new liberal Constitution and
it's been a disaster cuz it cuts
absolutely against the accumulated
wisdom of of previous centuries step
probably what will be a final word to
address that and also uh I think that
yes the Liberals relationship with
technology and also just that point that
James made which I think a lot of people
will find persuasive which is if human
beings are free to blah blah blah now
that we have the technology for people
to change their sex easily quote unquote
I'm free to be whatever I want why can't
you know isn't that what liberalism is
created well I think we are uh at the
gates of an equivocation here how we use
the word free so when we are talking
about liberalism we are talking about a
political Doctrine it's in a social
context what things are we going to do
with compulsion and what things are we
going to do uh voluntarily and then the
liberal has a way of dividing what is
done voluntarily and what is done in
compulsion now when we say that people
should be free politic
and socially we don't generalize that to
all of reality to say therefore you are
free to make up your own physics right
or to have your own version of the law
of gravity right or to uh to make up
your own biology and so forth all of
those metaphysically given features of
they're not political features exactly
why can't you're right that's right no
but the point is that the freedom the
concept of freedom is a social and
political concept it's not a physics
concept it's not a biology concept so
again if we are talking about people who
are uh in the transgender cons movement
this is another complicated territory
issue that we're putting out here but
the the clearly Disturbed right
individuals there who say I can be free
from biology I can be free from physics
well then we are talking about people
who are not rational right in any
liberal sense instead they have become
unhinged for whatever reason but that's
not the debate that we are having
between liberal think that's a very
sensible point and there's not much I
have to disagree with there so I think
we'll probably end on on a note of
consensus and I just qualify it to say
if you've got freedom as the highest
value and just and let's just assume you
can sequester it within a political
domain that's only going to work if
you've got outside the political domain
a sense of what makes life meaningful
that is shared at least to some degree
and I think that the stress on liberal
neutrality the
programmatic neutrality that liberalism
I think for all sorts of good reasons
wants us to have in order to bring about
Civic peace turns very quickly into a
programmatic neutral uh uh neutrality
which forces deep convictions about who
we are deep metaphysical religious con
convictions about who we are what what
we ought to be and what we ought to do
um pushes them into the private sphere
so that some those are questions simply
to be settled behind
closed doors between consenting adults
and so it's hardly surprising if those
questions are then bracketed that the
sequestered political Freedom becomes
the dominant the only kind of Freedom at
least the only kind of Freedom that has
any currency in the Public Square and so
it's no surprise that the liberalism
then mutates into progressivism with its
great doctrine that the personal is
political everything becomes political
all right gentlemen well first of all
thank you so much I thank our friends
here are unheard and uh before we start
on this actually we were talking about
the fact that modeling good conversation
uh is what we're trying to do so in the
spitter of that I'm going to add a
little flourishing flourish at the end
there and ask you what did you think was
Steven's strongest
argument uh I think step had a number of
strong arguments so it's difficult to
choose um I think by far the strongest
one though was this worry which I think
conservatives do not um take seriously
enough that by prizing the
particular uh conservatism don't have a
story to tell uh conservatives don't
have a story to tell about about human
nature and its broader uh broader
conceptions of of human significance and
morality that's why I happen to think
that the that particularity must be an
exempli exemplification an instantiation
of some broader broader set of
transcendent commitments this is why I
think you know a Rel the religious
impulse is a feature of conservatism not
a bug and that's what rescues it from
relativism but Steven is right to call
out to to to to to object because many
conservatives wouldn't disagree with me
on that Steven same question I say that
within liberalism there is again as a
big tent that you're quite right to say
there is the K version and in our
generation the RS version and I think
both of those are disaster versions of
liberalism so there is a tendency in
liberalism to want to generalize to want
to go to the abstract and if that is not
anchored then that is going to be a
disaster now this though does come to
another philosophical issue the
distinction between the empiricist and
the rationalists my version of
liberalism is going to be much more
empirically rooted so I think you
exactly right to to say that the more
free floating rationalistic versions uh
need to be reigned in or need to be uh
put on a better philosophical foundation
and they are problematic gentlemen thank
you for being here and thank you for
watching and listening we'll see you
soon with another brilliant
[Music]
episode